we row into and there you know you're
looking for answers so you know I get it
you know when you draft a guy early and
you know you're not winning games
you know these were them come up Eli
Manning on Monday recognizing what may
inevitably occur and it happened on
Tuesday Daniel Jones is in Eli Manning
is benched and Chris now the question
becomes do the Giants have to move on
from Eli Manning in order to get the
most out of Daniel Jones III don't think
they do I really don't you know I think
Eli Manning can still help a guy like
Daniel Jones out right now and I think
that the fan base says here in New York
finally put the nail in the coffin on
the Eli Manning era I think what they
saw the last two weeks they realized
okay it's over Daniel Jones we're
excited about it I don't think we're
gonna have a clamoring for Eli like oh
please we want to see him one more time
I think everybody will celebrate his
awesome career his Super Bowl
championships he's gonna get applauded
now when he goes on the field and things
like that but I do not think they need
to get rid of him for daniel Jones
development I don't yeah I just worry
about a couple of things first I worry
about Danny Jones looking over his
shoulder when he really doesn't need to
be if you're gonna make this guy your
quarterback he's your franchise guy you
don't want him thinking there's a level
of performance below which if I dip then
Eli Manny's gonna come back and also
don't like the idea of an Eli Manning
farewell tour in December which the
Giants are going to be tempted to do if
they're not in contention right because
let's have Eli Manning Appreciation Day
week 17 even though we're done we want
everybody to come out to MetLife Stadium
and pay for overpriced beer and food and
buy a bunch of Eli Manning swag on the
last day of his career I think that may
be one of the reasons why they're
keeping him around I just think that it
makes more sense now that he's not the
quarterback to move on from him
the best outcome would be a retirement
where maybe he gets some of the 10 point
four million he still do to make over
the balance of the season but if they
can't work that out then see you later
and you know I saw a tweet from Ralph
Aviano of
and why that manning has no immediate
plans to waive his no-trade clause what
doesn't matter if he has a no-trade
clause if he doesn't want to be traded
to a team that team's not gonna trade
for him
I just don't think we can get to the
point where the team that wants to trade
for him Chris I mean I look at all the
quarterbacks that are injured and
ineffective and I don't think there's
anybody right now who would consider
calling up the Giants and making them an
offer for Eli Manning even though it's
only ten point four million to pick up
his salary for the rest of the year no I
don't think so either I don't think
anybody really views Eli Manning as a
starting quarterback at this point you
know a point in time you know nor would
wanna they wanna maybe deal with just
whatever comes along with signing it Eli
Manning and you know teams were trying
to move away from these guys for the
most part I mean yeah okay you look at a
team like the Jacksonville Jaguars oh no
they think we saw Gardner Minshew
the Ginsu as you have coined the phrase
I mean he's certainly capable now me
yeah right but but I think this first
off just from a football standpoint the
Giants still want to have a backup right
they want to have a backup that they
feel okay can run the offense and be
good and I just could say Eli Manning
certainly better than the other guys
they got on that roster not named Daniel
Jones all right so they don't want the
season to fall down the tubes in case
Daniel Jones does hurt an ankle or
something like that the other thing I do
think that you know the Giants fan base
has finally come to terms with the fact
that it's the Daniel jones era and Eli
Manning's / if you cut him man I think
that would be viewed as very
disrespectful up here in the New York
area I really do I think the jet did
that would again piss the giant fans off
to go man that's messed up you don't do
that to Eli Manning and I think those
are the two reasons right there and then
third okay I'm manic so he has an
opportunity to go play for someone else
this year it's very easy to sell it in a
positive what Eli Eli would have to sell
that to it can't just be the Giants
doing it Eli's gonna have to be a part
of selling that because if it looks like
they're doing that to Eli then they're
not gonna be cool with that if you lie
is going you know I asked for this and I
think I have a chance then the fan base
will be able to do it but I don't think
they can just cut them and just go we're
doing this because we want Daniel Jones
to develop that will look crappy is
more disrespectful to have forced him to
stand there and watch than it is to tell
him it's over I think you could argue
that it's more of a slap in the face
that he's got to be there in uniform
wearing number 10 while someone else
plays I don't know about that I mean I
think it's more of a slap in the face
they like go hey we don't even want you
here can you get off me get off - you're
a distraction or you're bringing us down
you know I think that's more of a slap
in the face and especially you know if
it entails him not getting his money
then that's another big slap in the face
so no he gets his money he gets his
money that's the project he gets his
matter what right right I'm sorry
because he's on the week-one roster that
salary that's why they should they
should have done this two weeks ago if
you do it two weeks ago if you make
Daniel Jones the starter then of course
you're not keeping Eli Manning is the
backup at 11.5 million dollars you're
gonna get rid of him at that point and
the fans are gonna be upset because it's
a very easy argument to make he's not
the starter anymore we can't pay him
start a quarterback month I think that
still would have made the fans upset
here just you know having a little pulse
for this situation I think everybody
needed to see these two weeks of not so
good Eli to to kind of come to terms
with this and you know I just think out
listen I was surprised but I do want to
make the point I think also you know
when you look at the schedule
it's the Buccaneers and the Redskins
coming up for Daniel Jones two teams
that are not necessarily gonna go Super
Bowl defenses and I think they saw okay
Tampa Bay on the road not necessarily a
hostile environment
James Boettcher the Giants defensive
coordinator he learned from Todd Bowles
who's the Buccaneers demons coordinator
so I think he'll be very comfortable
there that's why they make the move but
I still see you say you keep Eli Manning
around and don't don't ditch him let me
just say one more thing let you say one
more thing before we go go ahead being
in a big market stinks it's tight they
gotta worry about what the fans think
just do what's right for the team they
got into this problem two years ago
because they were so worried about what
the fans thought when they benched Eli
Manning for Geno Smith yeah make
decisions in the best interest of the
team and don't worry about the fans if
you're making good decisions that are
going to result in winning football
games
it's all going to take care of itself
sooner or later
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports